[Music]
20 years later and that theme still
brings all the Zaza zoo fields it's
fabulous
yes it's been a full two decades since
Carrie Charlotte Miranda and Samantha
first clink cosmos and Ichi was there
from the start hitting up the Sex in the
City world premiere in June of 1998 it's
like living a life that's totally
illegal legally you know and I'm paid to
do it and it's been really thrilling
[Laughter]
countless I think there's a little bit
of samantha jones in all of us it was
clear the cast knew they had captured
magic I think it will find its audience
I really do it's not for everybody but I
think that that's what makes it special
and controversial it's on HBO it's nice
to have to have a smart comedy you know
comedy that doesn't offend anyone that
doesn't play to the lowest common
denominator that has some basis in
reality what's also funny nose looking
cap sir we're talking about the but a
cigarette is an order it's a little rye
Bob a little saucy but I think in many
instances it's conversations that women
have and I think it's very courageous
and fresh the deals with things that
people don't usually talk about
particularly not on television and it's
sort of refreshing to have people going
ahead and saying it out loud don't laugh
at me but maybe we could be each other's
soul mates it really speaks to women who
are in the dating game now in the 90s
I'm not going to
sugarcoat it for you he's just not that
into you that's not true listen to hails
and I'm really proud to be part of the
show
[Music]